Could you provide some information on dietary and supplements or gout management?
Well, gout and gouty arthritis is an inflammatory arthritis is what that is.
And it's usually flared by a diet that may be high in purines.
So you could google high purine foods or you probably could google a gout friendly diet or gout
natural gout diet, but foods that have a lot of purines foods that are sugary alcohol is the
worst thing for gout. I don't see a lot of people with gout when I practiced years ago I used to
see a number of people with gout and there are always people that were beer drinkers.
So it was very difficult to get them a stop drinking beer because usually people that are chronic
beer drinkers are you know alcoholics cause and alcoholics that can't stop drinking that.
But other foods can cause it too so you can be you know a non alcoholic consumer but you might be
addicted to sugar. That is a big driver of gout. Foods that have high purines are like organ
meats, red meat which is so good for cancer patients especially if you have anemia so it's tough if
you have cancer anemia and you're trying to eat more red meat to build up your red blood cells but
you also have gout. So that's that's a difficult thing. As far as supplements that historically have
been good for gout cherry juice and there's capsules of tart cherry capsules that a person could take
you can drink tart cherry juice it's very it's very tart by its very name but that has helped people
with gout lemon juice with water could help people with gout coffee could even help with gout so but
and then just you know making sure you're following the seven phases of detox because a lot of people
with gout tend to be constipated have issues with detoxing so even though you know they're not
drinking alcohol they're not drinking eating a ton of hearing foods and things there's not detoxing
very well so they give those kind of things